(soft instrumental music)
- Listen, when you're an entrepreneur,
it's stressful, it's lonely.
Like, everything is on me.
Right, like everything that's broken up
via intermedia, my fault.
(sighs) Fuck.
- [Narrator] The ones
who are successful have
this gutter, dirt, work ethic about them,
cause you're really almost lonely.
It's like you have the
demeanor of a king and queen,
you have king and queen, you know, values,
but you have to work
like a fucking peasant,
especially in this fucking industry.
- [Man] You know how many
people have committed suicide
in the tech startup community
in the last five years?
And there's not a peep about it.
Entrepreneurship is not on the pedestal
and everybody thinks its easy.
It's on you, there's no blaming anybody.
If this wins, you. If this loses, you.
That's lonely as fuck.
I have pain, there's always problems,
and when I'm in pain, I go
to sleep for five minutes
and I wake up the next
day and I kiss the world.
♪ I know, the world can't chain me ♪
- When you're the CEO,
when you're the founder,
every single thing that happens
in this company that's wrong is my fault.
Do you know how tough it is when you have
nobody else to blame?
You know how much fun
it is for you to blame
the person that's above you?
Oh, it's iHeartRadio's fault, oh,
it's Pidman's fault, it's my boss's fault.
That's fun.
It's very tough to be
at the top of something
even when it's going great.
♪ I suffer many deaths ♪
♪ I've fallen to the end ♪
♪ I've lied till my last breath ♪
- It is lonely at the top,
it's only my responsibility,
it's only my singular responsibility.
At the end of the day,
the buck stops with me
and I have to, with
every ounce of my soul,
try to deploy my north
star to my employees.
♪ Neglecting on my blessings ♪
♪ I'll always trust you more ♪
♪ I learned and now I know ♪
- It's fun and I love this space the most.
I loved it long before
athletes and celebrities
and rappers wanted to be entrepreneurs.
It was my destiny, it was who I was,
it was how I was wired, it
was the only thing I knew.
My entire life is taking care of crap,
putting out fires. Twenty-four
seven 365, my whole life is:
This is a problem, fix this.
And guess what, when you're the last line
of defense, there's no blaming your boss.
Everyday is hard and that's
the best fucking part of it.
- [Man] I'm gonna always
capitalize on that, you know.
And I believe that it's
time, like, all these
greats are dying now,
like, you need new greats,
we need new people that we can look up to.
I don't have a problem
being one of those people.
♪ Was it worth dying for ♪
♪ I suffer many deaths ♪
♪ I've fallen to the end ♪
♪ I've lied till my last breath ♪
♪ I'll sacrifice my heart ♪